Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to DOOM.
Now we're on Mars...
That's not really a revelation, we've been on Mars the entire time we've been playing. But I-- we're on Mars!
And that's an important thing to know.
Uh, but we did just complete that Rune thing
that I had to do again, because for some reason...
...the checkpoint system didn't give it to me.
So! We're about to go onto the surface of Mars, which
is the more important thing that I was talking about.
Hey! You dickbag, get away from me.
And, apparently, we're trying to do something
to get a Rune... or whatever have you.
I don't even know what it would be called.
Is it called a "rune?" Is it called...
What was it called? [quietly] I have no idea.
[Lost Soul cries]
Oh.
Hang on! I spy with [chuckling] my little eye, a lever!
Well, well, well. I found a secret already.
I have no idea--
[horn-like sound cuts him off]
...Hi?
Was that the war horn?
Does that mean I b--
I see -- I spy, with my little eye, an Argent... thing.
[stammers] a, a thi-- a, Ardent thing.
Okay, so...
Hup. Pull. No?
Oh, shit.
Um...
Ooh. EGH. Fuck-- AAH! FUCK!
Oh-kay! Well. [chuckling] Not what I wanted.
Heh. Ah, shit! God, you screamy bastards.
Get away from me, I'm trying to do a thing here.
There's something very important
up here that I need to get!
Okay.
Hupt. Oh, fuck.
Eh, eh, eh, eh, eh...
Ah-ha! Oh-ho, fuck. Okay.
HA-CHAAAAM!
PUH!
TUUUH!
It's really anti-climactic, for all the
effort that it seems to need.
Shit. Can I make that?
Hup--
Oh, shit! No I can't!
AH! FUCK! [screams as he falls]
Well... That didn't go as I had hoped.
That went exactly the opposite that I had hoped.
I sure I hope I don't have to do the God damn
Rune Trial again, 'cause that would suck!
But hopefully that's not it, and
hopefully, the thing is still thinged.
Ah, shit. Where am I now?
Oh, I know where I am!
Oh, that Rune better not be there!
I think it's not there.
It's probably not gonna be there.
Is that thing still flipped?
I can't tell.
Is there a...
Is there a thing?
Am I able to see...
...on the-- Ohh,  okay. It might be back there,
which means that it's NOT flipped.
I got to go flip it again!
I'm a professional fff-- switch flipper.
And they're really hard to flip!
[thud] Oww.
Alright, wait, hang on.
Well, that's not...
Ah, shit!
Ah, God damn it!
AAH, I did it again!
AAAH, FUUUCK.
[groans with frustration]
Well, I seem to be making a God damn fool of myself over and over again for everybody out there.
Aren't you glad that I started this episode with
so much... vim and vigor and happiness?
And suckage?
I have ample amounts of suck, everywhere you go.
Alright. Whatever. Last-- last time.
This time, with less stupid.
'Cause I've got way too much stupid.
Now where the hell do I
Over here.
Yes
This would... yes. This would be proper answers is~ yes ok.
SO LETS TRY THIS ONE MORE TIME
Without embarrassing muh-self!
AAAAAAAH! FUCK NO!
*sigh of relief*
*laughter*
Ah, titties!
They're blasting themselves all over me! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Okay, so...
*guitar starts to play*
If I'm not mistaken, and if I'm not stupid
Of which... no one is certain about that one
ok
uhh...
Hip!
Hop!
Hippity hop! HIPPITY HOP TO THE C-
AH!
Okay. We're fine! Everything's fine! Everything's 100% hunkidori!
What the fuck. *chuckle*
I think it's over here.
Umm... It's usually not TOO far away from-
Uh-the thing that you're trying to geeet!
So... AAAAAGGHH!!
I spy it! I spy it with my little eyeit!
OOOHH BOY!
Hehehe
I didn't...
This isn't...like, THAT important.
But it's cool!
Yaaay!
I got the Phobos Lab!
Phobos is the name of one of Mars's moons!
The other being Deimos!
Both of them aren't really moons, in the traditional sense.
They're more like...celestial satellites.
Which just means that they're asteroids that were captured in Mars's gravity!
In comparison to our moon, which was formed very differently--
The current theory being that it was formed with another planetary body impacting with Earth--
Is much, much larger by comparison--hello!  *gasp*
IS THAT PHOBOS??
I THINK THAT'S PHOBOS. =O
Yeah!  Phobosguy!
See, Phobos...
...in the game, is just another, uh...
Another DOOM-like character...
But not quite DOOM Guy.
I don--I dunno if he has any official lore, though.  I-I really don't know.
Man, these "secrets" aren't really secrets, they're just right in front of my goddamn face.
OH WELL, whatever.
HUH--*mouth fart*
Okay...
Lemme suck that power into my body, become a little more possessed by the De~evil.
Alright, soo...
I've gotten plenty of ammo, I've actually learned that my ammo situation is-is quite good, to be perfectly honest.
How do I get down there?
Ho-how does one do that?
It was open before.  Oh, shit.
Weell, that dudn't sound good.
Hup!
Okee-dokee, then!
I'll go in, thank you!
AHHH!
No.
Sto-sorry, we're closed!
Sor-ry!
Alright.
Where am I now?
I want you!  Oh...!
M'kay...
*bad Scottish accent* I'll play you'rre game!  YOU RROGUE!!
...Where the hell am I goin'?
Uhhh...oh!  Okay.
I got it!
Boy, this sure is a non-...OSHA-friendly...
B-uhhh, pathway.
Wonder what's over here...
OH, nothing!  Oh, a whole lotta nothing!  I wasted my face.
Slamming into that stupidness...
Okay.
What does that do?
OooOOOOH!  Bye!!
I bet that guy got sucked up into a whole lotta nothingness!
There's a lot of explo--whooa, there's a LOT of explodey barrels around here--AHH!
Diie...!
I said the thing that I needed to avoid, and then I standed directly inside of it.
That's the kind of keen strategist I am.
I is...
I'm not good enough for grammar.
Okay!
Well, I don't understand whut yer wanting from me!
Whut...?
AHH!  WAAAHH!
Oh, okay, I'm fine!
Everything's fine!
S'fine, it's cool!
S'cool, it's fine!
Hundred percent cool.  Fine.
Fine and cool, bruh.
Oh, hello.
Wh... Oh!
I got the Weapons Division.
Is this where th-there's gonna be a BFG?
Not really a secret!  Again!
Kinda just a room that I coulda wandered in at any moment.
But, oh well.  I'll take your secret as a secret.
EHHH
Aalright...
COOOL.
Err-kay...
Goo-bye!
Hii!
G'bye.
Go'bye.
Hi!
Go'bye...
Okay...
So that takes care of those guys...
One more!
For the road!
And there was something in there...
It looks big and shiny!  If it's a gun, I want it!
Ooh, I think it might be the BFG!
Hallooo!  Scientists, let me in!  I'm here to he--whoooa!
AHH!
Whoa noo!
Okay..
I thought I saw a Mancubus over here...
Oh, I did!  I was 100% right about what I saw!
Boy, it sure is close quarters to be playin' around with you--OHH!
THAT'S why it's green and glowy.  Ahh, okay...
I could chainsaw him, but that'd be a waste of chainsaw ammo.
I'm just gonna shotgun him.
Oh I'm not gonna make it!
AHHH fuck!
Oh shit!  Shouldna gotten that close!
Sorry buddy!
Okay, please die.
PLEASE die.  Ohow!
Why is this like that the way that it is??
Thank you.
Al-right...
Got that guy...
Eheh...
What about those guys?  They're kind of a demonic presence, dontcha think?
Mmaybe, maybe not.
Depends on what they qualify as a "demonic presence."
Ow!  God dammit, I got your f-wh-stop it!
Stop slappin' me, Sassy Slaps!
OOWOOH...
*chuckle* The BFG 9000.
Okay!
Remember how, in Dead Space, they wanted an "Ascension" too!?
It didn't quite work out for everybody!
They made a whole moon of corpses!
*glug glug*
And, speaking of "moon," this moon was about as big as Earth's moon, this is-this is no bullshit...
Deimos moon, this is a big, honkin' moon!
Actually, is Deimos the smaller one?  I can't quite remem-berr...
Test fire!
Okay...
Ooh!
What're we test-firing?
Ah!
Is that what we're talkin' about when we're talkin' about the BFG~?
Because I want me some-a that.
Is there--is there a BFG in here?
Heh, should I stare directly into this barrel??
HUH.  ANYBODY IN THEERE?
AHHO-kay.
Alright, anyway...
Goodbye!
Alright, I need to find out how to get this thing.
Shut up, asshole!
So, there's gotta be--ooh...
A whole buncha stations in here...
Station locked.
That guy did not have a good time.
I'll take this! *chuckle* Hey! How you d--how you doin'?
I'll jus--I'll just take that!
"Corpse Upper Toso Acquired."
GREAT!  Y'know what?  I, uh...
I dunno why I took that, but I got it!
So...y'know...I'll just...stuff that it my back pocket.
Where I need it....
Fer later...
Not 100% sure whyyy...
Ookay... Hello!
Can I have your bottom torso?
Thank you.
Perfect, actually, that's...
Oh, wow.
I never noticed the way the blood kinda actually sprays on the ground, that's weird.
Oh!
*stops reading the text in the middle* hebadebah...
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah!
..."Argent streams that seek out targets and boils them alive."
That's the only line you really need to know about when talkin' about this gun!
It boils your enemies aliiive...
Okee-dokee, then.
SOOooo...
Again, you're talkin' up this gun a whole lot.  How do I get my hands on it?
Hello...
Is this a secret?
Is this a secret!?  COME ON.
Aw, come on!!  This has gotta be!  LOOK at this!
Looks so secretish!
Aw, whatta buncha lies, what a bag of asses that is...
Hey, buddies!
Hellooo...
Sorry, I missed.
Didn't miss that time!
Not that time either!
Huh, still not missing.  How weird.
Poink!  Okay.
Oh, hi.  Ummm...
I dunno.
Is there anything else to do?
I guess I could test-fire this one.
Kinda be the same thing...
Huh.
PEWHH...
Okee-dokee, then!
Hm...
I think the basic gist of what they're trying to get across is that this weapon is literally hell itself...
OH!  Uhhh~...
Oh, thank you, Dr. Peters!  Have a g-good wuun...
Uh...
Um...
Uh oh!  NOOO-oh, shit!
*girly scream*
Well...
*crack*
OW.
What the FUCK?
Ohh, I was prolly sposedta, ohhh I kn-I know wha--I was prolly sposedta climb on TOP of the chamber,
instead of looking down at the ground, like a ninny, waiting to die.
WELL.
That was MY bad.
I apologize.
Alright, let's try that again.
AH! *glug glug*
*tsk pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop*
Uh-huh!
So far so goood...
It wasn't activated already?
Well, that doethn't theem g--OHH, HI!
Heheh!  Heh!  Ohhhh, that woulda been--If I'd've been standing on that thing, I woulda been veeeery scared.
Well.  That's instant death.
Huh.
It's like the world's most dangerous game of hopscotch.
I wouldn't mind playin', but I think I'll be over here.
"Weaponizing demons, for a brighter tomorrow."
AGAIN.  That Spokesperson is NOT on our side!
Oh!  Second pass.  I guess.
Just in case!  To make sure they're extra dead.
How long am I gonna wait around for this?
I got a lotta water to drink!  *glug glug*
Umm...
By the way, BFG stands for "Big Fuckin' Gun."
What do I...
Was that...
OHHHhhhh.... It'th a thing...ohhhh--whoa!
Bye!  Oh!!
WOW, that was an efficient slice!
Well, alrighty then!
I'll take this.
Thank you very much.
Ohohoho!  Woh-hohohoh!  WAAHAHAHH!  ER-HER-HEOR-HOR-HOR!
Owie!
Ow-Uh oh!
Whoops!
Well, I guess we're okay.
So long as me, and my gun, are okay, I think we'll get along just fine.
Hehehehehehhhh...
For a thing--it only has, like four shots, so you only use it for the biggest of the baddies.
"Access by pressing [T] - use it to devastate your enemies"?
It has it's own designated button, not just a number!  Holy shit.
It's a--big deal!
Alright.
Is there anything else in here while we're down here??
Any more, like, ammo or somethin'?
Anything I should know about?  Nope.
Aww, I missed that Field Drone.  Ahh, whatever.
NOOT A BIG DEAL. Not gonna worry about it.
Got other things to worry about...
Oh!
Ohhh, it wanted me to use the BFG~ theeeere, thaaaat...woulda been an intelligent use of my tiiiime.
I'mma load that so YOU GUYS don't miss out on it *chuckle* because that woulda been COOL!
UNFORTUNATELY I'M STUPID. =D
And...switched out for my shotgun, I d-I'm not 100% sure why.  Oh well.
AWWW!!
*sigh*
I guess I didn't want you to see something SO COOL...too much.
Oh.
Bye, everybody!
Go, go, go!
*sniff*
Soo...
Umm...
Wheere did all these survivors go, is the question?
Did they get outta here?  Did they escape?
I don't think that everyone died.  I'm pretty sure that not EVERYONE...
fell victim to the...dudes.
Oh, this is locked anyway, why did I even come over here?
So, there must be some survivors somewhere.  I mean, Hayden, it makes sense, but...
everyone else...
HI!!  Wooh, another chance!
Heh-blehhh--*operatic* BOO~OM!
Ohh, my god...
Wow.
Oh.
Oh!  Hey!
AHHH!!
*giggles*
It blows--... Basically, the principle of it, is-is that it blows up everything EVERYWHERE.
It annihilates...eeeeverything.
I'll save it for now, though.
'Cause I don't wanna waste it all.
I've only got one shot left, but...
I don't wanna waste it!
I~I wouldn't wanna do that...
Woop!
Poink!  DIRECT HIT!
Maybe not "direct"...
Whoa, what the fuck is that?
Wee!  Hoh-kay!  Cool!
I don't know why these're sittin' around here...
But, I'm happy about it.
Huh-whoosh!
AHHhh... This would make a lotta sense.
"rarrarrarrarrar"
Whaaaaa!
Hup!
Alright, saving this Quad Damage for more--what are you shoo--ow!
Stop bein' such a dickbag!
*pblpph*
Okay... Anybody?
Anybody else wanna plaay?
Youu doo?
Ohh noo~--whoa, whe-where-ere?  Where am I?
What the fuck?
There was no path around there!
I thought I knew for sure there would be somethin' over there!
Woop, nope.
It's amazing what you can do with a shotgun.
Hoink!  Ha-boofkie!
Ow, get away from me!  HAHH!
Ohhh, you didn't run away fast enough!
Alright, there's gotta be somethin' else here.
Somethin' to give me a challenge.  What is this?
Oh!  That was a BFG ammo.  Cool!
Oh, hey!
Nnno!
No!
Nno!
No!  No!  No!  No!
Ohhh, you're dead.  Okay.
Boink.
Uhh-buh-bu-bu-buhhh, so far so nothing big.  I dunno why I need that...
Frickin', uh...
Oh!  There's even more BFG ammo!
Man, they really want me to use this BFG, don't they?
Weell, I'd had to deprive you guys of perfect BFG destruction, but...
I reeally wanna wait until see something worthy of q-quad damaging!
Ehhh, maybe now is good enough.
AHH!
Wooaahh-booshkie!
Welp, everything's dead now.  Except for that guy.  Fuck that guy's shield!
S'a loada bullshit!
Oh.  You look like BFG-worthy!  Hah-buffkie!
Ohh~ noo~!
Hehh, you esplo~ded!
Why're you still alive?
Alright, I'm quaddin'!  Doesn't seem like anything's worth it over here.
Boink!
Aaaand--by your feet!
Oh, hey.  How's it goin'?  Can I get a--HAH-BOOSHKIE!
WA-BUSHKIE!
Oh no, another one!
Ah, shit!  T!
BFG--AHH FUCK I WAS GONNA QUAD A BFG!!
Ahhh, I got stupid, I-I went for--I always go--I always die when I go for these fancy things,
Like, "ohhh, I want a BFG with a Quad, mehhh, I's just a freakin' idiot!"
Alright.
Let's be a little better this time.
Maybe a little bit.  Not MUCH.  I don't wanna be TOO much better!
I gotta go who-through that whole endeavor again.
Which is stupid, but whatever.
It is what it is!
HELLOOO!
Mm-blelaph...
Ow.
My fucking face.
I was standing by an explodey barrel, apparently.
HEH-BOINK, okay, we're generally back into the better parts of what we're do--OH shit.
That guy, I hate shieldies!
Alright, TAHM TO DO THI~S.
And then, TAHM TO DO THA~T.
Ohh, you, I forgot that you were a thing.
Oh, welp, you're dead now, so I guess no one's really worryin' about it!
OHH, time to do this!?
Oh, you're not...you're not the Mancubus.
Where's the Mancubus?
Where's the goddamn Mancubuseseses?
Where's the Mancubi?
Oh, there's ONE.
BAAAWWWH!
Oh!  That got 'em all!
Heheh!  HEHEH!  HEH!
That got 'em all anyway!
I guess I don't need to worry about that!  Thank you!
Thank you for participating in my little experiment.
Helloow...
AHH!
Get away. Get away!
I said GIT AWAY!
Oh no.  Oh no!
Ohhh no!  Ah, shit, didn't make it.
Poink!
That got it.
That made it.
That made it into giblets.
Anybody else wanna--oooh, it's a shield guy down there.
But he ain't gonna last long.
'Cause I say so!
P-ahh!
Fuck you!  Your strong ass!
Er, your--s-your, specifically your ass, that is strong.
Alright.  What else we got??
Hellooo...
Aaaaaand, nothin'.
O-kay!  Got 'em all!
I DTHIIID IT!  YAAAAY!!
Okay!  Is this where everyone is?  Are they all deeead?
Or did they surviiive?
Oh, again!
Well!  Oh, hello!
Barrron of Hell!
Ooh, I can to do this!
AHHH!! OH-WAHHH!!
Oh my god!  Whooa my GOD--OW!!
God dammit!  What da fu--I wudn't ready for this!
Gotta give me warning before you...friggin' douche up the place with your doucheness.
Alright, hang on!
Hang on, I didn't--
Hang on, I gotta...
I gotta figure summin' out--shit!
AaAAAHH!!
Fuck!
Fuck you!
AAHH!
HE-eey...
Ah sh--awww!  I blew myself up!
Well, I didn't know that they were gonna be comin' around the corner!
I woulda gotten some health or somethin'.
I woulda prepped!
I thought I was duuun...
Didn't have any goddamn BFG ammo left...
They didn't leave me any...
Least I wasted my gas on choppin' that guy up, that was pretty cool.
Alr--AWWWW, what the fuck??  I'm back here!?  Fuck YOU GUYS!!
You assholes!  What the fuck?
That's a load of bullshit.
Hebbedeh-hebbedeh.
Okaay!  I got it again!
Ummm, that--man, that is unfortunate that that takes so long...
I mean...mehh, it's my fault for not payin' attention as to what I was supposed to be doin'.
So, I'm gonna chainsaw one of these assholes.
And I'm gonna BFG the fuck outta the other one!
READY?
Let's plaaay!
HehuHEHEhehuHE....
Who's up?  HI~II!
WELCOME TO THE PARTY--OHP! Too late for you, I guess.
Hey, where'd the other--where's you friend?  Huh?
Two is a party!
Tw--ohh, he's DEAD, oh no!
Wow, that-that got rid of him good.
I guess a direct hit from this thing'd kill pretty much anything, except a Cyberdemon...
Which, I imagine, I'm going to be facing soon.
I did realize!
This whole time that I've been playing, I haven't really...
Y'know...
Faced a boss--aww, I was so close to the last one!
Ahhh, I did TERRIBLY this time!
I did TERRIBLY.
Eugh!
Euugh!
Ah, whatever.  I did-did what I could!  =)
I did what I could...
I couldn't, uh, be expected to do any better.  Okay!
Alllrighty then.  That probably means I gotta go back to hell at some point, and punch it in the face.
Just like I punch everything else in the face.
That's how I solve all my problems!
Especially my emotional ones.  ;_;
*weep weep* Oh, hey.
DEEP, SO DEEEP...
Ugh... *glug glug*
Okay.
Maybe I've seen it already!  You don't know that.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, y'know?
Maybe, maybe s--maybe a little bit of somethin' of that.
Didja--oh hey.
Who was there??
Ohh, it's the flying heads again, they always spook by...
Ooh.  Hello.  Howzit goin'?
Gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme, giv--
Okay...so.
Facing into this next area with a little more professionalism...
And a little less douchenism... Hello!
Is that the hologram guy?
MEE?  Are you talking about ME, you flat-ter-er?
Oho, awww...
Y'know, Olivia, if you just wanted to...
Take me on a date, you could've just asked, I mean I wouldn't have...
I would've said no.  I-I would've 100% said no.
I only care about kickin' ass.
UUUMMMM....
This doesn't seem like it was any sort of a secret, soooo...
Whyyyyy did no one else in the entire facility know about this?
Hello...
Hi.  What the fuck is goin' on with this shit??
What HAPPENED in this place??
Who the fri-- What the shit??
Ahh, shtop it!
Bye!  Heh!  Hehe.
Man, this is just so bizarre...
Like, all the--all the faith-based ideas behind this stuff is...it's just really interesting.
I mean, it's been--it's been done before--WHOOP-DEE!
Oh.  Hello.
This isn't gonna work!
Hup!
HAHH!  There we go!  Blasted your butt apart!
Okay...
So...
Lemme just make sure...
'Cause I got the-the update that shows all the items whenever they're around...
So I just gotta make sure that I actually go to everything...
So, it looks like the proper way to go would be down that hallway, and there's nothin' else around here.  Okay.
So.
If that is the case...
Which it might be!  Hang on, let me see somethin'...
Hey!  There's something down there!  How do I get down there?
Probably by going this way, and then going down and around, like the map said it would.
But I didn't pay attention to the map!  I'm just going on instinct.
My...PURE 100% gamer instincts.
Ohh, nohohooo...
Euuhh, you got stuuck!
Ohh, he was probably so young!
And, uh...
Eugh, not so supple...
Alright--oh, hey.
Heey.
I let your friend go!  Why aren't you happy to see me??
Ah, whatever.
I guess I can get this thing goin'...
'Cause I-I don't really use much of the Plasma Rifle, and it does give me a lot of opportunities.
Hehy, I found a secret.
MEGA HEALTH.
Thank youuu!
There was something e--hey!
Uh-huh.
Okay.
I remember this from, uh... From, uh... Like, uh...one of the trailers or something.
It was, like, on the Steam trailer... I can't remember.  This area looks familiar, but I can't remember exactly.
I think so.
Hep!
G'bye.
OOOOH, I want to touch this!
With my fist!
Wuh-byeh!
Alright...
Ohh, no.
Ohh, they are in cages!
Fascinating.
Faaascina-ting.
Okay.
So, th-that's really interesting, they-they literally did harvest demons...from hell.  Brought 'em here.
And then used them for experimentation, then released them...
For--So...All of these demons that are here...were..only here...
Because...wooh--hello.
Hey buddy!
So, all that--I mean, what I'm trying to--sorry, I'm trying to think and fight at the same time.
This is not workin' out too well...
Hehh-bye!
Hebeh!
AHH!
Stoppit!
I'm tryn'a...do things!  Shut up!  I'm doin' a let's play!
AHHAHAH!
Don't be like that!
Don't be like that...
So, in the initial invasion, uh, the only, uhh... demons were around here,
unless those gaping mouth things were actually...helping them infestinate--I DUNNO I'M TRYIN' TA THINK.
AHHH!!
Got 'em!  I got 'em!  I gahht 'em!
*high-pitched* boink!
Okay...
Huhp!
Whoop!
Hoohp!
*raspberry* alright
AHH!! Hi.
Welcome to the party again!
AHHHH-booshki!
Alright...
Oh, how do you survive that??
Ya nonsense-induced bitcheloid!
Alright, here we go.
Boink!
OOOHH...
Boomph.
Bloomph.
Ahh, get away!  Get away, get away, euughh!
Geww!  Goo, gross.
Gross.  Grabby hands.
*mouth fart*  Okay!
YAAY.
Eughh...
Uughh... Okay.
Soo, yeah.  What I was trying to get at, what--didn't come through properly...was that the intial invasion...
Was only demons that were here?  Or, did the demons somehow figure out a way... with which to...
summon more demons from Hell.
But, that would mean that individual demons have the capability of doing that.
And, there's a lot of hellish runes around here...
Hehe-oh look!  BFG ammo!  Just lyin' around, in-in the cells, with them.
The most secure place to keep that would be with the demons themselves, i-is my imagination...
God dammit.
Okay.
So, somewhere in here...
There is...
Some...
Stuhff.
Over there.  Okay.
So, if I gooo around, and around and around...
Hokay!  I can do that!  It's on the other side, over there.
Prolly where I was hippity-hoppitying around.
Alright, lemme just grab the rest of the ammo that I can...
And then move on.
I don't use my rockets enough, but frankly I think I'd kill myself with the rockets
if I was ever given an opportunity.
Hey!
This Jessica person!
'Cause...the Revenants!  I know what happened to them!  The Revenants, they no do too good!
Why would anybody want to be a Reven-ant??
Man, there was a lot of operating under the...improper assumptions around here.
A lot of assuming a lot of things about a lot of people,
that, probably, people should've asked a few more questions for...
And not been so "faithful"...
But, then again...
It is a vidja game!
It seems like, somewhere there'd be a secret.
Hello?
Ah!!
That is the secret!
Halloo!!
I was wondering where you would be!
Hi~ii!
I'll take that.  Don't mind me.
EH HEHH...
Ookay!
What did I get--a Research Token--or not the--Praetor Token.  I need to use the Praetor Token.
AHH, there we go.  "Elite Guard," FINALLY.
NO NOT THAT.  The Elite Guard!!
Alright.
Huh.
So...
THAT'S why they're all DEAD.
Well, what, wh-th-did they just find private nooks and crannies with which to masturbate in??
Was that the reason why they all died in seemingly sporadic areas??
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED and why would they kill 'em all??
It seems like they woulda been very useful in the event of an invasion...
MUCH LIKE THE ONE WE FIND OURSELVES IN.
uhuh
Yeh...
Funny 'bout that.
Lotta people is that way...
Man, I don't have a lot more things to goo...
Be-be-be-be-buh-buh-buh-buh-blplplplplbb--II~II don't knoooow--Stun Bomb.
EHKAY.
BOINK.
I mean, I'm not gonna use it much, because I-I intend to use the other thing.
HUH-boop.
Because I wanna get the Mastery in that one before I do anything...
Cloaking.
Umm... Where am I goin'?
Uhmm...
*dumb voice* I have a question...
Where the hell--oh.  Above. Oof course!
Allrighty, then, who wants some?
Anybody?
Anybody want some?
Anybody at all?
"Some" is available in all quantities.
Anything that you require.
Mm-okay!
I heard some rumbling, I th--ooh.
Ooh.
Ooh...
Oh, no, that's nothing.  I thought those were holding cells for giant monsters, but apparently I was wrong.
Her-bleplhh
C'n I go through here?
Yes.
DOINK.
Eh, who needs to grab it oh-so-gently...
Ahh, these hands weren't built for caressing!
These hands were built for PUNCHING.
Wait.  "Monsters; Cyberdemon"!?
Huh!
What--FUCKin' THTOP that!  "Cyberdemon"
Cy-Cyyberdemon.
*bored Mark gets bored* Blah blah blahhh...
BLAhhh blah bla-- "piecing the creature back together"?? o.O
*gaaasp* Waaaait a minute...
WAAAIT a minute.
"ancient battle in the Titan's Realm"??
They had to piece it back together??
WAAAIT A MINUTE.
WAAAIT A MINUTE, was that man the original DOOM!??  EHHH??  EHHH--Maybe.  I dunno.
Maybe maybe maybe.
Maybe...maybe there was some weird temporal thing where, when I went to Hell in the original DOOM...
there was something along the lines of...
going back in time, or-or time got really weird, or...or what have you--whoa.
Something, uh...
Something broke out!
I~I don't know what, but I would hazard a couple guesses.
Hehe.
Huhh...
HUH.
Lookit dis!
*high-pitched slur* LOOK AT THIS.
Whoa, lookit all this!
Huh... Something esploded.
Something ass-ploded.
Alright, anyway...
That's interesting, though.  That's very, veeery inter--WOW this place is big.
HOOLY shit!  Okay, so that's where the entrance to the, uh... Wow, what the fuck?
That's probably the entrance to the thing, but how does one get to the thing?
There's quite a gap there.
So, around here somewhere...is a lever!
I'm gonna find this lever.
I'll be right back!
Okay, nevermind!  I had to look it up.  This is not the area where that is, so NEVERMIIND! WE'RE MOVIN' ONN!
EVERYBODY CARRY ONNN WITH YOUR LIIIVES, it's not that big a deal.  Okay.
So... the Cyberdemon has escaped, and at some--
AHH!
Hi.  Heh!  Nice tuck-and-roll there, dickbag!
How you doin'?
Hope you die.
AHH it's a big guy!
W-OHH NOO!
I blew his entire back out.
Now I blew his entire face off.
I might as well blow the rest of 'im!
Maaaybe.
Hallo!
Aww, nobody left ta blow...
Don'tcha hate it when that happens?  AHH!
Oookee dokee, then.
Hey, friend!
Ka-booshki!
I SAW you.
Ow.  You hit me, but I SAW you.
Eh.
Umm...
Alright, so we got a couple ways we could go about this.
How 'bout that one?
Mehh, I like that option.  That was my favorite option.
Her-yer-ber-ber-berbitty-boo, ya-bop-bobbity boo ♪
Ehh!
Heh-boof!
I missed!
I missed!!
Ahh, I missed again!
Fahck, why do I keep missing?
Ahh, shit dude.
One of these days I'll get him...
Ah, shit--WAAH! There we go.
Got him!  Uuwaah!
AHH!
Shit!  Rahh!
I mean, uhhh, exactly what I wanted to do!
Perfect. <.<
Uh, preciiise-ly...
Whoa.  What the hell happened here??
EUGH!
Were these guys transformed, or did you experiment on them when they were fully human--
You c--tu-turned that guy into a frikkin' lump, what the fuck happened here??
EUGHH.
eyughh...
Grotty...
GROTTY.
Alright, hang on, I gotta check.  This is a long hallway that I just went down.
Uhhhh, you're lucky there's nothing around here, because holy shit!  Uchh...
Alright.
CARRYING ON...
Who's around here?
Uh-huh--whoa!
Oh, I fell!
OH, what is THAT?
Oh, heehey!
Howzit goin'??
Hang on, I'm lookin' at stuff!  Stop doin' this!
Oh, shut up!
Shut up!!
Hmphh-*fart noise*  Okay.
What the--HOW'D THAT NOT GET YA?
There we go!  That-that's better.
Alright.  You!
Please die.
You.  Fall over.
You.  Forge--forget entirely everything you ever hoped for.
Okay!
Woo!  Helloow!
Hallo!
Halloo!
Good-bye!
Alright, where am I now?  Oh, I see!
Umm--buh-bum!
Ya-boooi-la-da-da-dee! ♪
Ya-dah-deee, ya-da-doiiii ♪
Ya-dah-n-dee~ee ♪
Man.  They did a looot of shit here in the Lazarus Labs, I gotta admit.
Boink.
Okaay, that guy dead.  That guy dead.
Anybody gonna pop outta these things?
Should I be worried about an--that's a BIG operating table.
I mean, MY GOD.
You'd think someone woulda raised ONE eyebrow...
about anything that's happening here...
No?  Nothin'?
Not a--not a single concern, from anyone in the peanut gallery?  I'm goin' for the...
The frikkin' quad damage.
LE'S DO DIS.
EHHHH-boink.
Anybody else?  WHOA-noo~oo...
Whoa, NOO~ooo...
His shield didn't stand a chance.
Hah-baphki!
Hohohoh, my god!  That guy got ethploded!
QUAWD.
QUAWAHHD.
Anybody else?  You?
Alright!  Quad all gone!
Aww, one more left out of the party.  I'm sorry, buddy, I didn't mean to do that.
Nyoink!
Sorry!  Okay.
That everybody?
Yeah, pretty much!
Y'know, those automatic lockdown systems don't make a lot of sense,
when the whole place is filled with demons anyway.
Even if they are caged up, it seems like a bit of a problem.
Oh!  That guy is...sliced in bits.
Did I~I get to him?  Did I do that?
Eh, probably.
That guy's still in one piece, though.
Okaay... So, let's see...
Is there anything over there?  Absolutely not, huh?
But there is something...
Up above me...
Over here.
Hullo!
"Proceed at your own risk" *giggle* "open sealed area"
Huh!
Eh, alright!  Y'know, I'm okay with this.
This doesn't seem so bad.
For a sealed are--I gotta use those Praetor Tokens, because I've been...
I've been hording them nonstop, so I gotta use them...
Ummm, Environmental Resistance, that would be nice.  Immuminin to--that's perfect.
"Immune to explosive barrel damage."  I.  LOVE it.
Umm, what else could I do, though?
Uhh, upgrade systemmm... "improve the effects of powerups" would be niiice....
"speed of certain actions" would be nice.  "Switch weapons faster"  Very good.
"Grab ledges," I g-I g-I g-I guess...
"Swap weapon mods fa--" Yeah, that's not exactly... The first one was okay, and the second one was mehh...
And the ss...they're goin--alright.
"When a power--a damaging blast wave is released" sounds good.
"Upon activating a powerup, heal--" oh.  That sounds good too!  I li-I like the sounda that.
Let's see--"Extend...length of time..." *mumble*
Eh, I woulda liked to spend more on that, and less on the douchey ones that I had before.
But, whatever.  Beggars can't be choosers.
Not that I was begging in the first place, but I'm choosin'.
Boink!
Thank you!
Alright, what else we got?
I'll get there in a second...
Ehhh, might as well.
God, I really needta upgrade my armor.
uuuUUMM
HI~I!!
HALLO!
Can I throw this through there?
Nope!?
Huheh, the answer is no!
HI FRIEND.
HOW YOU DOIN'? Oh--I'm in here, now, I guess.
This how this done.
Hup!
WAAOW, that's what it do!  Boink!
Boink!
Ow.
Die already!!
Friggin' asshole!
Boop.
Man, that blast-wave is really good...
Woobadooobadoo!
Stopped him in his tracks!
pthlbh
Ow!  What the--WHAT DA FUCK!?
Oh my god!  I got destroyed by an IMP!
Well that doesn't--Oh.  Hey!  I needed those!
I...Ow!  I needed that too!  OW!
My lights!  You knocked 'em out!  Well, that was weird.
Uhh, I don't think that ONE Imp had enough to be able to knock my socks off, so let's try this again, shall we?
Ow!
Noot that one!  Nooot thaat one!
That's not the one I was aiming for!
Shiiiit...
Ah, whatever, it's good enough!
Goood enough!  I'll take it!
Ahhh, beggars can't be choosers, where I've heard that one before...
Okaaay!
I'd like to think that the majority of that was caused by, uh, explodey barrels, and not me.
That's PROBABLY what happened.
*noisy lip smack* If, *smack* If I hadta guess *smack smack smack* Probably.
Memp-hem, mm, probably.  Probably, probably, probably, harumph-harump.
Haaarump-harump!  What is this?
What is happening here?  Oooh!
Ithh zhat a thhecret I thhee?
Ithh zhere thhomthhing behindh here?
OHH-ho-hoh!  Hellooo...
There i~is!
A~ahh...
Drop down here, what do we got?
*high-pitched* OH!!
Hi!  Heheheheey... How you doin'?
Cutie.
Alright, there was somethin' else over here, too...
Oh, I see!  One of these is an actual Rune-rune.
No?  Was that not it?
Looks like it.
OH no, that was the--that was the mega health, that was the mega health. Got it, got it. That was the mega health.
GOT II~IIT--
Doink!
*pop pop*
And away we go!
Wait, so, are we still in the same map-- Oh!  Hello.
Okay.  Mm-alright.
Um...
Li'l strange.
Li'l...li'l--li'l strange.
I'm beginning to think
that guy's not entirely on our side... HAYY!
It's a stone! Whoaa-ol!!
*high pitch* ...ol. Well what do you know? Well what do you know?
Oooooo! Access blocked?
Here's your authorization!  Heuhh..
euhh...
euhh?
heuHH?
Alright, fine then.  Fuhck YOU.
Got my symbol on it!  Apparently, I dunno why...
Maybe we'll get to the m--deeper mystery of why I'm here.
Hmm... *tsk*
I dunno what any of this means!  O-kay!
What about this?  Eugh, that's a little grotty.
Why is that stone infested with flesh?
Or, why is that flesh infested with stone?  Who knows which?
Huh!  What a...buncha bizarre artifacts.
Man, the whole concept of using Hell for science, is just...really interesting.
D-ohhkay.  Goodness gracious.
Alright, what else we got here?
Oh, it goes down!
There's a DOOM guy up there??  Why is there a DOOM guy over there??
How the hell would you get to that guy??
There's nothing theeere!
There's NOTHing THEEere!
HUH-OHhhh NOoo!
Okay, so there's something back here.
Might as well just carry on!
*lip smack*
Huh!  I feel like I'm being led somewhere!
Huah.  I bet this is a trap.  I'm gonna bypass it, like a bowss!
Alright...
Who ya talkin' to?
Well, someone's unhappy with me being alive.
Huh.
*reading faster and faster*
*breeeeath*
*cuts off halfway through*--okay.
Alright then!
BOINK!  Boink!  Boink.
I~I know what I'm doing, apparently, for some reason, somehow--hello!
Hiii...
That's interesting...!
WOOooh...
aaAAHhh...
A bAAAbyy--a demon baby.
Umm...
Hm.
*tsk*
What's with the sword-slicing I hear?
Oh, that!
I needed that!  Good.  More BFG stuff for ME.
Never enough BFG ammo!  If you ask me.
Ooh!  Is that a penis?  I dunno.
What's with the babies??
Are they tryin' to clone me or somethin'?
YAAAY.  I was waiting for one of you.
Boink!
HurrrRAAGGHHH--*mouth fart* I pooped mahthelf.
Alright.  Movin' on!
Ignoring that that happened...
alright
Health, nehh.  Ammo, nehh.
Eh, health.
Eh, I'll do health.  Gotta do health.
If I could keep the mega health long enough, that'd be a little bit better.
So.  This guy.
Hm.
"Helix Containment Field"
SEEMS like a bad idea to turn off...containment fields.
O-kay.
Huh...
Why is all this hologram except for the face shield, which is just...reflective visor?
Oh no!  It's the inside of my head!  Ehh, shit!
*dumb voice* Ehh, shit, dude.  Ehh, shit, is that me?  Ehh, shit, dude.
Eeohh nohoho... This is what I was talkin' about, embedded in stone.
Who trapped me?- is a good question.  Who put me in there?
Certainly, it wasn't MY choice.
Why did they just seal me away instead of destryoing me?  Good questions all around...
Boink!
AHHhhh!  Mah BRAIN!
Oh!
Huh!
Okay!  Is that, like a Keyblade from Kingdom Hearts or somethin'?
Maybe?
Huh.
Ooaa-II~I don't get it.
Okay, I'm gonna have faith that you know what you're talkin' about!
I kn-I know what they're talkin' about.  But still.
How do we know that it won't just blow ME up?
'Cause I have a funny feeling that there's a lot of things here that could just blow ME up.
And I don't like to be blown, I like to do the blowin', please.
Hep, okay.
Boink!
Anybody else?  Hi.  Hi friend!
Oh no!
Ohno!
OHNO!
OHH no!
OHno!
Boy, they shoulda sent more than just Imps!
Boink.
Oh look!  They sent more than just Imps!  Ohh-uh, oops!
I spoke too soon...
AHH--buh-bubububum!
I'm stuck on something, I dunno what though!  There we go.
Right in your biiig ugly face.
Huh-*raspberry*
WEEE!
It's like a Needler, but waay cooler!
Eaahh..
*mumble*
Eyeh!
Oh, shit.
Hep!
OhhHH, oyeyeyey!
OH just in time, baby!
Oh, hello.
WOO-boink.
I'm down here now.  What're you gonna do?
Whoa, THA-yeah.  Theere we go!
GOT you.
Cack-o-demon!
Cack-o-demon cockin' up ma day!
Hehhbedebedebed--I'm low on ammo, low on ammo!
GREHH--there we go!
Thaat's what I'm talkin' about.
Eyalerlerhh...
*metal music intensifies*
AWWHH YEAH!
The music just kicked up all of a sudden!
It always seems to kick up halfway through the battle!
Oh my GAHHD!
OOUUAAAHHH IF ONLY THERE WAS MORE STUFF TO KILL THIS WOULD BE AWESOME
Welp.
Shit.
Ohokay.
Umm...Oh, there ya are!
*high-pitched* Boink!
Ahh, I missed!  Hang on!  Lemme do it again.
Boink!
Ahhh, shit.  Not direct hits.
Well, that was sad and disappointing!
But what else isn't in my life, eh?
Whady--meh-mm--*dissolves into sobs*
*sniff* Fine.  Alright.
Goodbye!  Nice staircase.
Who the hell built this!?  And why the hell did they build it so mysteriously like this?
Who the hell's idea was all of this anyway??
The Faith?
Ow.
Thtop it.
Thtop it!
THTOP it!  Theriouthly.  Thtop it.
God, FUCK the shield guys!  Seriously, fuck the shield guys.
Okay.  So, is this where everyone went?
To meet about discussing the possibilities of blowing the shit out of the whole world?
Oh, sh--OHH, right in his grundle.
Well.
Uhhh... Okay.  Well, that probably didn't kill him.
Why are you doing ritual sacrifices again?
You wanna run that by me one more time?
Hmm...
Okay...?
Oh, one more time, for good measure.  Better-better do one more.  Yeah, just one more.
Yeeah, why not?  Why not?
Mbeahh!  That was a good one.  That was--that was really a good one.
*lip smacking x3*
Is this just gonna keep...goin--alright, you know what?  Fine.
Ehm, I'm--Ohh, that was it.  Okay, you were done there.
Ohh, look!  Nice skull!
This is looovelyyy.
Especially THIS one.
eughh...
Alrighty then... Where am I headed?
*Marki-noise*
Okaaay--wooh.
Hey! *giggle* HeheHEY!  Just chillin' out?
Howzit goin' there, buddies? XD
Just havin' a good old time? Aw, I understand, long day at work, you wanna kick back and relax,
have a few brewskies... It ain't no problem at all.
Ooh, I think... YES.
Okay, I looked up where the other one was!
I didn't know it was here!  But it looked familiar, so I got it.
Huh-bonk!
*imitates game success noise*
And, down here? Huh-*mouth fart*
Thankyou!
"Secret"...goddamn "secret," it's just a hole in the ground!
But the real secret is...
WHOA-VER THERE!
...Oh.  OVER HERE!
Ahh, cooool!
COOOOL!
Oh, man, this freaked me out!  Because, I was like... When I first saw this, I saw that Barons of Hell
were strung up on the wall.  And that made me go, like:
"=O HOLY shit!!  Whatever strung THESE up is SERIOUS about its business!"
This is actually the last, uh, level of Episode 2, and...it is no fuckin' joke.
This is where you meet the Cyberdemon.
And I have a funny feeling that we're gona be meeting the Cyberdemon relatively quickly...
Wow.
Hi, guy!  Man...
Hep!  Alright.
Let's do whatever the hell we're doin' now!
HUH-bip.
"Do not stand below lid during dithh..."
During DITHH?
Oh!  Hello!
Ithh that the dithh??
Uhhh, okay!
Beam me up, Scotty!
NyeeEH?
AHH!
Sorry, I got scared.  I thought something was coming after me.
Mmm...
Okay, anyway!
THAT is actually all the time that I have.  I'm glad I hit a checkpoint just there.
But we've made a lot of progress!
We made a lotta mistakes too, but I--I'm no--I'm including "we," I'm saying "we made mistakes."  Together.
'Cause we're in this together.
But, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And, as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
Bye-bye! =D
*Haunted outro*
...hanging right there.
...Okay!
Alright, I'll-I'll just fall over then...
Don't mind me.  Nap time.